[Applaudissements]
j'ai eu mon premier ensemble de golf
quand j'étais un jeune adulte temps
quelqu'un de relativement responsable je
me suis dit je vais me pratiquer avant
d'aller sur un terrain de golf pour la
première fois donc c'est ce que j'ai
entrepris et pour ceux qui sont plus ou
moins familiers avec le golfe je suis
allé ce qu'on appelle un champ de
pratique un champ de pratique
essentiellement c'est un grand terrain
vague avec des marqueurs de distance et
les gens s'installent avec leur
équipement plusieurs balles et répète le
mouvement de golf énormément de fois
jusqu'à temps on l'espère tous il
s'améliore pour avoir une meilleure
technique donc c'est ce que j'ai fait et
j allais seul à ce fameux champ de
pratique là donc je me suis dit je vais
d'abord trouver une façon de mesurer mon
progrès je vais devoir avoir une façon
de me donner une ma propre rétroaction
pour savoir si au final je vais dans la
bonne direction
donc ce que j'avais à ma disposition de
plus facile et le plus accessible
c'étaient les fameuses distance que
laval parcours et donc naïvement je me
suis dit
si j'arrive à frapper ma balle loin ça
va potentiellement faire de moi un bon
goal fois alors j'ai commencé à
pratiquer frappé beaucoup de bars
toujours en gardant en tête que je
devais envoyer les balles le plus loin
possible
après un certain temps évidemment j'ai
peaufiné ma technique j'ai commencé à
avoir des résultats intéressants
mais à ce moment là j'étais accro je
voulais toujours frapper plus loin
c'était rendu mon objectif en soi alors
j'ai continué à pratiquer mais j'ai
commencé à modifier légèrement ma
technique des fois j'allais faire des
choses qui allait me donner un peu plus
de distance on parle peut-être dizaines
de mètres de plus mais j'allais
introduire des variables dans mon élan
de golf qui était uniquement dans le but
d'aller plus loin
éventuellement je me suis dit bon j'ai
pratiqué ac c'est le temps de mettre
d'utiliser ma nouvelle expérience de
nouveaux golfeurs et d'aller sur un vrai
terre est ma grande surprise ça a été
une catastrophe totale
ce que j'ai réalisé une fois sur le
terrain c'est que oui la distance c'est
un élément clé mais la précision la
constance de mes coups c'était tout
aussi important pourquoi parce que sur
un terrain de golf et des obstacles il y
aura de la forêt il ya des plans d'eau
des trappes de sable donc oui je
frappais la balle très fort mais je la
poussière mais dans un endroit où la
pression pour mons prochain coup j'étais
en position difficile et au final à la
fin de la partie mais j'avais un score
qui était plutôt décevant
pourquoi je vous parle de ça en ce
moment ce soir c'est parce que j'ai
retenu une bonne leçon de cette
expérience le camp j'ai été moi même
capable de constater les impacts que ça
avait eu toute ma pratique qui était
aligné seulement sur une métrique c'est
à dire la distance que je parcourais que
ma balle je me suis dit j'aurais aimé
avoir quelqu'un à un moment donné qui
viennent mais interpellé me dire il ya
d'autres métriques que tu vas devoir
considérer et qu'ils vont faire de toi
un bon golfeur à la fin j'ai gardé cette
leçon là en tête tout au long de ma mise
études et de ma carrière et maintenant
je suis rendu au professeur à
l'université de sherbrooke en robotique
et
je suis capable de faire certains
parallèles avec cet épisode là de ma vie
parce que tout d'abord en tant que
scientifique j'ai un objectif assez
général qui est d'amener des nouvelles
technologies les nouvelles solutions qui
vont bénéficier au plus grand nombre
c'est un peu mon idée partie de golf
parfaite c'est d'arriver à faire une
différence
maintenant comment qu'on peut mesurer
cette différence là moi je travaille
comme on le dit en robotique et plus
précisément en audition en robotique en
reconnaissance vocale ce que c'est
essentiellement la reconnaissance vocale
si je doit simplifier énormément c'est
on prend un signal audio et on tente
d'analyser les mots de les reconnaître
les mots qui ont été prononcés dans
l'extrait audio
et naïvement ce qu'on va utiliser pour
mesurer la performance de notre analyse
c'est la quantité le pourcentage de mots
qu'on a correctement identifiés en
d'autres termes idéalement on voudrait
avoir un taux de reconnaissance de sang
pour ça ça veut dire qu'on a reconnu
l'ensemble des mots qui était présent
dans le segment c'est notre objectif
final
dans les dernières années vous avez
sûrement entendu parler vous l'avez vu
dans l'île les présentations précédentes
l'intelligence artificielle occuper une
place phénoménal dans le domaine
technologique mon domaine a également
été
je veux pas dire nous n'a pas été
épargnée mais disons bénéficient de ces
avancées là et on a vu des avancées
phénoménal en termes de reconnaissance
vocale donc l'intelligence artificielle
c'est un terme assez général mais on
parle souvent ici de ce qu'on appelle
l'apprentissage profond l'apprentissage
profond ce essentiellement créer des
modèles mathématiques extrêmement
complexe avec des millions paramètres
qui vont permettre de produire des
prédictions pour une tâche précise dans
mon corps en ce qui me concerne c'est la
reconnaissance vocale
on a observé qu'avec ces nouvelles
méthodes là on allait chercher
maintenant des taux de reconnaissance
qui dépassait l'état de l'art des trente
quarante cinquante dernières années avec
les méthodes plus classiques on s'est
approché de taux qui frôle de plus en
plus 100 %
mais évidemment il ya un revers à ce que
les modèles qui sont énormément complexe
demande une quantité de calcul
importante surtout moment où on
développe et ont créé ces modèles donc
on utilise des ordinateurs pour ce qu'on
appelle entraîné les modèles et c'est
évidemment pas des ordinateurs comme
ceux qu'ont à la maison c'est des super
ordinateurs dans des centres de données
il faut une quantité phénoménale de
calcul pour vous donner un exemple
l'entraînement d'un réseau ce qu'on
appelle le réseau neurones ou un modèle
d'apprentissage profond on peut parler
de plusieurs semaines d'entraînement
pour des centaines d'ordinateurs dans un
centre de données
si on regarde l'utilisation
d'électricité que ça représente ça peut
être facilement ce qu'on aurait eu
besoin pour alimenter un petit village
pendant 1 an d'électricité
on arrive donc à un point où en tant que
scientifique on s'intéresse strictement
pour le moment à la performance en
termes de taux de reconnaissance c'est
devenu un peu notre métriques qu'on
utilise pour évaluer à quel point notre
objectif comme scientifique se rapproche
de notre idéal
ce que je vous pose comme question en ce
moment c'est si j'ai un tour de
reconnaissance de 98% sur mon téléphone
quand que je vais prononcer quelque
chose le fait penser à un taux de 99 %
qu'est ce que ça va m'apporter comme
individu en terme d'expérience en termes
de retombées qu'est ce que ça va
apporter à l'ensemble de notre société
vis-à-vis
l'entraînement de modèles qui a pris
plusieurs semaines s'est faite sur des
ordinateurs extrêmement énergivore et
dans la plupart des corps en utilisant
des énergies non renouvelables
parce que vous savez qu'à l'exception du
québec est encore beaucoup de pays
industralisés qui utilisent le charbon
et le pétrole pour produire de
l'électricité on arrive donc à un point
où est ce qu on fait une obsession sur
la performance numérique qui le tour de
reconnaissance
un peu comme j'avais cette obsession à
vouloir frapper ma balle de plus en plus
loin même si c'était pour aller chercher
quelques mètres de plus moi ce que je
propose que je pose comme question c'est
est ce qu'on devrait pas faire un pas de
recul et se remémorer c'est quoi notre
objectif final pourquoi qu'on fait de la
science pour quoi que moi je fais du
génie pourquoi mes collègues enfants
c'est peut-être parce que au final on
veut avoir une solution qui va
bénéficier au plus grand nombre
dans le contexte actuel la communauté
scientifiques utilisent des métriques
qu'ils tendent à s'éloigner parfois de
ce cet objectif là qui est plutôt noble
et qui est très très très spécialisés
pour des tâches particulières
donc ce que je vais amener comme point
aujourd'hui puis c'est une question que
je lance mais j'ai pas la prétention
d'avoir la réponse ce soir même c est ce
qu on peut revoir nos métriques est-ce
qu'on pourrait repenser comment on
calcule les performances de nos systèmes
communs qu'on s'auto évalue entre
scientifiques pour que ça reflète mieux
les besoins qu'on a comme société je
vous pose la question je sais que des
scientifiques parmi nous je sais qu'ils
ont également beaucoup de gens de tous
les domaines et je pense que c'est une
question qui doit d'avoir inclure tous
les acteurs pour être capable d'arriver
à des
optimisations qui vont nous amener la
direction qui va bénéficier au plus
grand nombre
donc
aujourd'hui je lance la question ce soir
je lance la question et j'espère que
d'ici quelques années quelqu'un pour
prendre la place et va arriver avec des
propositions qui vont être intéressant
pour nous permet de permettre de
rectifier le tir pour aller dans une
direction qui va bénéficier au plus
grand nombre et on l'espère de nous
rapprocher de notre partie de golf
parfaite merci beaucoup
[Applaudissements]